damn Russia meddling in our affairs
Russia's putting enough bread that was
30 minutes to this point out I give a
[ __ ]
bread and I I know you're wondering but
I I once went to the dermatologist
because I've been itching my back and I
you know me you know me I'm on it I get
in there and look good he comes in
usually everyone know but you're gonna
she's got her glasses on and I go I
seriously clearly have you know
something going on you know and she goes
I don't see anything
your boss is just itching it's been
itching until you get like a mother to
you why don't you it should be less of a
[ __ ] listen to I do you like - I don't
know my back kept bitching you get an
inch so you guys I didn't you just have
an itch I go nope it keeps hitching I
had so she looks at it we start talking
I go give it one more look she goes I
hear ago ha
there's nothing there yet nothing yeah
where the [ __ ] are your braces they are
I've been wearing them hard and a lot no
Joe's mom were said then then stuff like
talk to she's like John I see your eyes
he never wears no I don't wear I'm sorry
ass but I wear them during the day she
goes even twice a week and I wear them
at night yo you don't yes I do I swear
to God I do you missed a big weekend but
it was in Vegas my first year Cecily
retired right yeah now now I I need to
get some color on that because you
didn't you were very you didn't really
answer my texts I was busy all weekend
right so you go you go - I know you went
to the fights I wasn't worried I wasn't
really planning on it
our boy Todd Feldman was like hey man
gonna fight gotta take it
we have nitrous pot in the plane oh my
god and then there was I had to do some
business out of business meeting there
so it kind of made sense you know I'm
not gonna go for fun right and so I went
on the plane smaller private plane oh
yeah and it was not a dull triple right
Oh ha it was comfy it was nice but so
the people from Mac and D from Always
Sunny who I absolutely love they're
amazing right and then I'm sitting with
these two guys and Todd and I assumed
everyone was from Always Sunny and
they're talking the time I how they're
filming their like area actually
the island and two weeks to start
filming and to last season I'm like
dance crazy man they're talking I go
dude I only got get to kill dat man
we're always sunny when for starting
he's like what and I'm all yeah you guys
really gets changed me start from
Paddy's Pub men in Ireland that's nuts
and the guys like what and I'm like what
is going on right like you can somewhat
like a what
and she's going back forth and then tie
goes bro there's a riders in showrunners
four games of thrones of the king on the
throne and I want you on the world about
the speech oh yeah and I mean huge and I
went oh just drag I send them you know I
do that bad with other dragons and I
think is what the Dragons Gale I don't
want you I don't watch it but those guys
were bleep a barillo as it got fun to
Sado every one of those episodes there I
was really watching it last night so
smart yeah it was they were so
interesting and then we I was with them
all day so tonight just smart smart
smart in the eyes smart do yes it talked
about how the first season and they went
through and I'm sure people are balls
deep in games of Thrones are like what
got [ __ ] ass commitment but it was just
is cool man yeah you're gonna have to
say Gaines drums oh it's not games no no
it's not just a me up thank you again to
say Game of Thrones
don't say games of Thrones games they're
only two things that bother me when you
get those things wrong when you say
Royals Royce as opposed to roles right
anyways so though I asked it was the
question I had for them I told my said I
do not watch it never really had any
desire even though it's the be show ever
right started watching last night we got
back home yeah you'll get into it and
you'll get into it takes a little bit
and then you'll be into it but they were
saying I was like you know it's the last
season I'll see you guys have people
knocking down your door to write
whatever is next for you or produce or
whatever the hell they want to do so you
gas be the right project I'm like it's
gonna be like same genre like with you
know with Knights and swords and they're
all hell no he's like I'm so sick of
horses arm and it's it's just I always
think about that because when I watch
the show as an actor those kind of shows
kind of ruin it for me because when I
see people in mud and I see them wet and
I see them and I see their breath the
cold
a breath and I go I know that they're up
at 5:00 and I know how cold it is and I
know that they're wet and I know this
shoot all over all over I know that
they're in the middle of nowhere
somewhere up in Ireland or and it's not
it's it's a [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] they were like when people
the guy I know who did lost he was again
it's Greg a Hawaii he goes yeah Hawaii
until you're on the sand all day and
those fleas start biting your [ __ ]
ankles and legs and you're wet all the
time it can get on the sixth day when
the your shorts are rubbing yeah you can
get crazy you know yeah we going game
ladder oh so that's how problems are
that's the problem is you can't say I'm
poor me I'm on Game of Thrones it's the
greatest thing the world but when you're
in armor all day it's a [ __ ] it's not
it's it's it could be away from the of
course but physically it's super
uncomfortable and on the tenth day when
you're working on no sleep it'll get to
you but you can't tell anybody know
you're young compensate for it so shut
your [ __ ] mouth compensate it to a
degree yeah those are those actually
give me the top ten yeah now they do I'm
insane now they're yay everybody
renegotiates
probably Tufts I would I would argue
that top five not top ten top ten yeah
yeah think that you know yeah it was a
spam I mean aalverson okay yeah I I
don't know about top ten I don't care
what your agents say I thought it'd be
them yeah you might have other inside
source I just just what happens with
actors when they're on a hit show like
that he lost they really want to be
knows how is it that they want to be on
the show so badly so what they what the
right I was they said yeah I know you're
a lot of times I'll be language w I'm
just saying what I wanted eyes who run
game would yeah but sometimes I'll go oh
I mean we may have to just write them
out and then I'll wait and say okay yet
I'm sure there's something ahead good my
[ __ ] yeah they get a Peter Dinklage is
getting hate look
yeah I don't know you can talk to but
heard they make decent money I yeah uh
anyways they were great to hang out with
though I'm sure the smart to shore this
might do they like to fight had they
ever seen fights before oh yeah they're
balls deep
oh they are yeah they actually come in
my live show in
Dublin Wow they're filming out there
that's amazing time so we come to my
shows up there awesome
yeah they the the one guy knows it
pretty well man the other guys knew a
shitload about you see their Lots
they've been to a bunch of you what did
you think of the sights of the five year
point you're born they right I was at
the arena was bored too I was a little
nervous to go to the fights I was glad I
was going with those guys who are in the
fight world yeah it was good to go that
crew she cuz I haven't been since I
retired man if you feel that fabric ever
doing got completely robbed let's go to
the file okay to be cheap liken trying
to talk about my weekend so going with
damn I I'm just nervous they're not so
balls deep in the fighting so it made it
better and then just seeing all the
fighters man it was just a bad anxiety
and if that wasn't a right away it yeah
all the fighters is great well why did
you have anxiety just just how you style
used to do that for 10 years and it's
like UFC and I don't have any bad blood
with anyone but even then pull all the
employees were great to me everyone's
great to me I didn't mean Dana's in
cross paths I'm sure we well because I'm
I'm thinking announced today by tense
comes I'm sure the press release to be
out but I'm I'm officially work in the
the pre and post-flight shows for the
the worldwide tour for Showtime and so
I'll see Dana's gonna be there so I'm
sure I'll run in tear there but there's
I have no laughs I'm also the biggest I
mean as far as voice for Mayweather
and Conor how long have I been pumping
this fight
yeah I mean I'm putting money in his
pocket nothing I needs it but I'm a huge
advocate for this line as far as MMA
angles goes there's no one who did you
see that you had not algid for like did
you see so I saw Big Nog I said what's
up to him gave him a hug um I mean saw a
wonder boy Joey Benavidez all your boys
all people all my boys man I saw Cody
gar Brant everyone man yeah everyone
everyone
it's called statements really get hugs
from mom and just yes cool man yeah
there's good go Todd he bet so so Todd
likes a bet on the fight and he goes you
know he doesn't bet like pennies right
he shows me his list and he was huge II
bet on
and listen this has nothing to do with
Travis brown any ill-will actually we
can get to that fight I said I would put
money on this Russian and here's why I
went because one thing you know about
Russians they have no quit Travis he's
lost less four or five you know and I
don't know how bad he still wants to do
it when he fight this stuff of Russian
with that much experience I like him as
a dog so he put on a shitload of money
on that Russian look what happened
Wow yeah that show i'm but the snowed
arena was I kind of half filled until
the main card started there just wasn't
like a lot of buzz I think Amanda Nunez
pulling out that put just and I don't
think that would that necessarily hurts
the numbers that much because she
unfortunately she's not that big of a
draw but just kind of put a damper on
the whole kind of experience overhead do
you have a main event although that
you're Whittaker man that was amazing
and the best fights in middleweight
history but it was just the I don't know
there's like a weird vibe no one's
really that excited for anything on if
that slip was in him but then once you L
and wood is a little better but in
general the crowd was kind of I would
explain is like blah yeah
oh did I post that pictures Franciscan
oh yeah yeah me and him wearing mine and
he's waiting for hot dog and heat any
come in and bumps me no they do you know
him no I've never met him but you know I
I talked about him he's unproven let's
not give him the belt yet he joked about
it about it that's awesome he's great
how do you think that she's huge not
great
now not great he is big he's taller than
you I thought he's tall she's thin
though he stayed he shredded but he's a
little thin yeah he's making dick as you
are I'm actually crouching down in that
okay okay that he's not like six-six
anything like that okay I'll actually
like I'm like put my I'm like this wrong
me wrong he's [ __ ] a sure but yeah
yeah but it's really that's great
anybody no one has any Anna animosity
towards me anything Lee now I think
you're always gray hair all is it it's
cool she's all excited to see me and you
know and ask about you know comedy and
stuff like ooh a man sure it's cool
that's really is great you have a full
circle time good idea I just realized
that
to say when you told me you'd gone to
the site so I was like Dan that that's
the first time you've been back I think
right am I wrong is that was that the
first time yeah I mean also I work both
or what you not stuff so yeah I can
imagine it would be very very kind of
housekeeper nerves lost quiet in the car
car in a Mack Rob Mackel like forget but
Rob Mac Mac from Always Sunny was okay
you're nervous sounds like I'm not
nervous I just have anxiety going there
right now man yeah and I told music do I
complete image did you go back stage
yearning yeah go around yeah yeah that
was cool but yeah the fights were just
you know they just didn't deliver that
happens but when the main event does it
usually saves the card the numbers I
think we're gonna be low no matter what
I you know with the mana news you have
any I made a Nunez news is you know I
was yes do you know anything about what
their numbers are do you haven't got
yeah they're a Blas act on the UFC I got
the overall bull food the reason why it
is so this has been the worst first
court in a long time just because you
know this is the transition the people
run it don't know what they're doing the
promote they're trying to get their
promotion going you know they just kind
of they don't know what they're doing do
you think that they'll do anything like
a.m. 24/7 what was that I'm sorry all
the time out Conor yeah like for the
other okay well show time also the other
ones yeah that dude I don't know whether
there are a lot of stories you can tell
right
especially women like especially in this
new sport for women and women are
headlines like the embedded series I
don't know if they still do it but
there's the countdown on Fox that I
watched there alright but they don't
really dive into they're not you know
they'd film in those six weeks for a
fight yeah almost too late I feel like I
just talked about fighting yeah but yeah
the fat with Amanda Nunez you know said
her sinuses but was it is her sciences
yeah do you have a thought on that
because you I'm looking at your scalp
you have hippo eyes right now I have
hippo eyes I have a number of feelings
on this what I don't like is how data
through under the bus yeah I don't like
that a female for stature who's a multi
time world champion who's beaten Miesha
Tate Holly Holm she's beat
Jenko before Ronda Rousey yeah yeah of
course she's been in bigger fights so
for them to to like say she'll never had
a lot of yet again critique er and kind
almost like shun her and like shame her
and all that I'm like this is your
product like in I hate to tell you know
you'll see brass and you Kokura realize
this but the with the you see Brad Stone
realizes the USC it does not sell the
fight the fighter sell the fact which
it's never been more clear go ahead and
put on any fight you want if there's not
a fight that people know and care about
you're not getting rating that's right
and it very clearly shows in your first
quarter so when you say oh we can make
anyone a superstar full of [ __ ] how's it
worked out for Paige Vanzant how's it
worked out for sage Northcutt you keep
trying to push these people on us no no
we smell the [ __ ] from here man yeah
you can't it's not the way it works so
when you when you talk bad about your
product a champion the day of the fight
where she gets cleared medically because
they did whatever exams she goes I'm
telling if I you punch the face of me
real trouble I'm not doing it and and I
know people go oh that's [ __ ]
fighter slightly save it you've never
been a fight in your life you know fun
at this professional level she loses
that fight for whatever reason cuz her
head she feels especially a punch to me
an issue then what then are you gonna
help her pay her bills or gonna help her
recover right how's that worked so shut
that [ __ ] up if it doesn't work like
that man
so for her he knows her attitude to go
he knows her man I know they cleared me
I'm telling you if I get in this any
[ __ ] trouble and I risk losing it all
well I promise that you're talking about
somebody who is a warrior and couldn't
be tougher right it's already proven it
was right so so when you like a sage did
it I'm not like that says I don't want
to fight okay
after they proved themselves so many
times and they say they want to fight
something's up and we should give her
the benefit of the doubt knowing her
body why when you say you don't which
this let Dana
I don't need Dana come out and even tell
me what it is right if you go listen
this is how you salvage your your world
champion who's your biggest star in the
women's division and you don't tell her
[ __ ] story we salvages go man
unfortunately she plows there to fight
the dot you know she's just
feeling right were supported fully we
know exactly what's wrong you know she
says she can't find me she can't fight
yes so you got everyone and does anybody
have any doubt about Amanda Nunez his
commitment her heart and her warrior
spirit does anybody are you really
suggesting that she bailed out of the
fight because she had a mental issue
whatever here like what are you [ __ ]
she talking about is where this is where
people who don't have respect for the
effort so will they mother what they've
never done it if you either of I but at
least I have deep respect for what it
took to get there to literally punch
kick and submit her way to the top she
my first initial reaction I went oh it
must be really bad and then in the crowd
this gentleman said behind me was
talking my ear off does not she's scared
my let me let me stop you there scared
of what was she scared of scared of a
girl she's already beat scared of Ronda
Rousey's the best of all time scared of
the other girl who consider well that's
all timing should take which one is she
scared of right what does [ __ ] know you
would be scared that's right she's not
scared of anything right as far as
competing this is what she does she you
talk about a girl who came from nothing
that the other fighters she had to
borrow their workout clothes cuz you'd
sleep at the gym on the gym floor now
she has this beautiful house in Booker
Etan you think she wants to give all
that up she's scared to fight a girl
she's already beat what's before the
[ __ ] wrong with you right what world
are you living in that's insane but it's
a lack of respect
it's a contempt with the figure-four the
courtship [ __ ] rolls downhill so when
day does ah they I've never had a fight
or do this it's all mental that said
that's that's the one thing that's a
cyborg you know and then it's taken her
a while to come back who knows never
comes back from those kind of well he
didn't mean a thing about Dantas he was
talking about cyborgs where it's like
you know recently he was like you know
we are a lot we haven't handled it well
we haven't treated her very well okay
you know a little late for that right
and so so I my feeling I always say this
is about Dana I feel like he gets really
emotional and he he speaks without
thinking he gets emotional and then
he'll reflect and then come back and go
maybe I was a little hard to suit I six
years Brian well he's been doing it
Peter
every single table would sighs I think
it's our model dammit responders yeah I
think damage is given on an out I think
it I just think it's a personality I
don't sure it emotional sure I think
that I think it damages his the brain I
think he gets you at woods damage in
demanda more than anyone cuz I'll get
labeled as that it's just there like a
respect man it really hurts my feelings
to be honest but the thing even would
Amanda back down you know yeah you have
to offer people their money back on
tickets but it's not like it was a Ronda
Rousey or a Brock Lesnar
you're the john jones situation the day
uh you know it's like you're still gonna
be your card is what it is it wasn't
that great of card but now you have an
out and i honest blame it all on a man
and and as you point all the things that
are that's not her
and she's down to fight in edmonton it
whatever is 215 so she is yeah yeah of
course she's like that yeah we'll run it
but just get me fix this problem yeah i
find me us and other fights i didn't so
that i didn't think that heard I thought
um you know I thought pedis Ligurian cm
Miller can you say he's back that's
extreme to say he's back you did break
his hand
I thought he looks really good like I
and I guess so oh I mean Jim Miller has
maybe one or two left so let me get the
tops off standing so like just so in his
grill like just standing right now
they're not of yeah I guess he just
that's cuz he's got a longer fighters
right Jim Miller would throw those loopy
shots who just get out of the way right
right I thought again I hope I love
Pettis so I hope he's back it's not same
in every wants to jump on these hype
trains and always look great against of
an older Jim Miller man a shorter guy
it's tough to say you know he lost four
out of five any ones this one it's yeah
why didn't he win his last one no he
lost it he fought that 145 couldn't make
the weight in longer uh he looked good
hehe let's go to 55 I liked him um
trying to fight other flights were a
little rough well so let's let's talk a
little bit about um trust rounds yeah
cuz cuz II can I tell you what what I
felt like it when I because he was doing
well periodically stun the guy got him
down well I don't know how to say his
name strong or squared only Nick Olynyk
fully holding polexia Alexei Alexei
Olynyk
and he limit I guess he's a monster
wrestler a monster wrestler he was
surprised to Travis wrestled him when
Travis lost cannot you know I thought to
myself I thought man I feel like he's
probably very happy in his relationship
he's got money he's living in a probably
a nice place in Venice or wherever in
some in California maybe he is done like
maybe he's just like [ __ ] this you know
and I'll see a problem with it like you
know Bueller I see on social media like
all [ __ ] Travis this and this it's
like man you have a great career like
this is how it ends for every one of you
stick around to everyone in the world
this is your favorite fighters if they
stick around too long this is how the
game goes or if they drowned or they
stick around when they have one foot in
one foot out or you know like so Albert
he might like his other life better than
this Spartan lifestyle you know I mean
there's also that everybody kind of gets
to the heart of there's nothing wrong
with that I just think he needs to stop
like cuz now you're just hurting your
legacy like he had a great record yeah
he's had a great career it was this five
out of six there's this four out of five
now and then his four out of five I
believe he lost this is fourth in a row
now but then think before that his last
win was poking that material in the eye
lets you know that that's not really a
win is it cuz they were you know but so
his last win is me DuckTales dick jokes
it so it might be time to you know it's
I just he just heard in his legacy
Derrick Lewis I'm rich of her damn came
to lasso really one hon hon two three
four five six and eight nine he's won
two others last nine suck on that
and one of those wins is against Matt
Mitrione with the hi folks
yeah the others against me for god sakes
it's like yeah I just don't I don't get
why you're doing it but then look at the
way he's losing to I mean that dick
Lewis was up horrendous Cale now for be
so burden was a straight [ __ ] beat
down like he didn't I wasn't competitive
now Cain Velasquez straight [ __ ] beat
down in the first round
yeah so you know he's losing pretty
violently to that Andre Austin Romero
that fight that was [ __ ] rough and
then you know he loses temper doom gets
out class and fights me it's like
for your time I the guy who's a monster
like when he burst on the scenes man I
remember most of habits we talk like
Jesus Christ I'm sick I got a scam just
like he he should have with his and you
never know things happen man but you
know he should have been the next champ
and just seen it look at its potential
but to me this isn't a sad story it's
like this is how a man imma go this out
and you just even Dana was like I just
thinking he's retired and there's
nothing wrong man get get your girl
pregnant to have kids bate liked it he's
at a great career hopefully has money in
the bank I know he was getting paid well
like there's nothing wrong with this but
we can't do is keep sticking around and
you know so you might win his next on
lose to win one like what are you doing
yeah for what man well a lot of people
that's their identity for you know it's
a very strong identity and it's hard to
walk away from all the lights and
everything else but you know you got
after a while maybe my boy some money on
that one though ah pedis that Curtis
blades Daniel is cursed blade to that of
Denver
there's fun because I saw Cody Cody and
the whole team was there oh you did Cody
in the back awesome
yeah I was terrible and then Cody goes
yeah because what you think my boy it he
looks like a monster like I know he's a
good wrestler but that fight was or he
and he goes easy just learned out a
punch 26 years old yeah he's that right
that's what it looked like he looks like
he's he's got two ways to go even Rogan
was saying you know he's got I guess a
lot of potential athletic potential but
yeah you look like a monster and I told
good so hopefully they keep him Russians
who get tired but not not hating on them
but so you can get more experience and
with a strike that Russian guy that
looked like he had not been missing any
meals i rushing out I'd be retired phone
but not enough sea caliber flight and
now he is he does not have a currently a
seat so let me ask you it not be there
very long now excited I might come up to
this one right so that's what I would
ask you I don't know how how you get in
but when I looked at him and I was
watching him fight and I was watching
the coyote waiters how do you get in
heavy weights just because you need to
fill is what's his record I'm sure it's
pretty decent clicked on none of them
Daniel Daniel where curse plate is above
Jim Miller I mean he he was just which
of his record yeah he'll pile in these
winds up
Oster Struve Johnson so he's been the
UFC but we betta he beat Alexei Alexei
Olynyk who beat Travis Browne Wow it
means you know Sochi he's gonna your
feet for a little while he wants three
in a row than lost three in a row yeah
but you know he just he won't be there
very long he just he's not the caliber
don't know what they do um but I know
that fight I think got bumped up because
um a man in nuna's right all right I
think ah and then over in ver doom so I
think I think Oberyn I think for Doom
got robbed oh my god not at all okay so
hold on there's two rounds were clear as
I watch that in the first round again I
watched the first round turn over in
February I'm telling you right now I
watched it zero happen at minute - I
mean but with two minutes left I mean so
[ __ ] over doom was pushing the fight he
was the aggressor also bring caught him
with a couple of jabs sort of I mean I
don't think anybody one that that round
and I would give it to Burbage over doom
because he was the aggressor at least I
mean literally nothing happened that's
in that first round nothing and then
Alistar did work in the second round the
third round for Richard Burton beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of another last service
and then and then shot on it which was a
horrible mistake which is I don't know
I've redeemed it did that he hasn't
wobbled he shoots alright
and then sits in his guard that was
weird he's way too much of a veteran not
averse to wait way too much of a veteran
to do that you could have finished him
on the feet man I don't see this as a
robbery at all yeah well no I was like
that really I gave over in the first
round second round the third round
without a 10-8 round although someone
gave a 10-8 round did not uh didn't did
not recover him knock him down and knock
him down drop them isn't that it when
you drop him isn't that a no isn't that
a 10-8 usually uh just depends
you're saying that third round he
knocked him down yes no didn't know he
wobbled them and shot a double like you
cannot even get dropped in one round for
sure from my memory over never over
there with that drop really not good
this morning our job I can look it up
check it out this right now is I
definitely think
for Brazil won that round very handily
and so I ground yeah yeah third round
yeah um and here's a question about
overing that I think is very fascinating
and maybe it's me but every time I see
him fight when he starts it's almost
like he has a completely different style
every time he fights as I thought he
fought brilliantly I thought he looked
great you know I'm saying that he's
precise calculated didn't rush patient
and with his hands down he's just
waiting forever doomed to throw he's
such a high-level striker he's literally
waiting for redundant so so you can
counter I played was great
we tough to beat man I thought about ver
doomed
that was ver dooms fight to lose and he
definitely found a way to lose I think
if it went in the fourth round every
room wins at handily to stop them who
cares that does nothing but I do me goes
first around he did nothing Verdun team
fight yeah he sure did the third okay
well I want us up for grabs on of which
around it was but um maybe the second
because remember over in wobbles them
then I mean Verdun wobbles in and goes
for guillotine and jumps to guillotine
and loses the guillotine this cemetery
fighting go the first round what did
they fight their first round round one
they scored ten nine as well yeah I
thought that was easy ten I got beyond
the first two I like that one this round
went man for Doom has skill finisher
yeah I did see the uproar at all I
watched that twice I just didn't see
anything man you know um because we're
doing lanzar kick and it's the best
track meeting so far strong body kicking
Alvarez coming forward so the first
round I'd watched I just couldn't
I'm with MMA fighting on this I I give
it over and I literally the first two
rounds like oh yeah it was a knee
remember we're doing hitting with the
knee and then he fell down yeah I'll do
the ground yeah yeah what's wrong if
they say knee here saw see where this is
for the third round yeah over him is the
defensive I'd never do fine lads a good
knee over he was on the fence one two
huge me over his intro for Doom trust no
no he no no he rocked him and jumps to a
guillotine that's how they end up on the
ground he never put him on there I'm
remembering this completely wrong then
you had never happened he's Rocky he
rocked them with a knee then throws a
one-two and overran covers up and then
he hits him again and jumps to a guilty
I really need to look this up on now
yeah and then they stand up and then he
shoots her double I had him beaten him
that's insane it's not insane forever
for Doom the first round is awash I
don't know who won I would give it to
over him because he pressed the action
he'd give it to over yeah
because he was trying over him on the
flight I'm sorry I would give it to bird
to him because he was pressing who's
pressing expressing to take grass over
there copy strike numbers bring up the
come straight newsroom attune so the
first round is very tough to call man
second round not tough to call it
started round clearly for doom so how do
you easily give it to him if the first
round stuff to call one guy he'd split
round so he could because I put more
weight on the third round and I think
that the third round was more than I
sense though I think got the sport I
think the third round was more decisive
as well but slept losing he land is way
more on the third round then over and
landed on them in the second round
that's why that's the other reason but
it's just not do we could seek fights so
if you land more and do more damage in
the third round then the other guy did
to you on the second round and landed
responses for brother if you're later on
your head yeah in the Brian Collins
world then then I guess he won like how
if the sport works right you can't have
any judges judge it how the world judge
is hit it doesn't work like that
well how does the how are you judging it
though because if he go round by round
right here's ten nine or you know right
the world does not drop with the third
round is not way more sent out and I'm
that way the first round
yeah and any facet you just can't do
fights like that I get you want to yeah
so you can't critique and say this guy
wanted more than the third just debts
Brian Collins way of judging a fight
right
which the rest of the world okay well we
go by what weather so bitsy the first
round I don't know who won
and I I might give it to Werdum just for
his just for being more aggressive so
that's that's where I'm looking at this
we can't be strike two yeah we'll just
fight metric server doom round one looks
like he landed more right as I was
saying landed by target no so he landed
so he threw 30 punches and he landed 40%
over him through ten punches land 50% so
so just by looking at the numbers so
Topher Doom landed more because 30 40
percent of 30 is more than no but no so
check it out the you go by percentages
so landed four shots of the head
consumed late for every punch III length
70% of them so he landed twelve punches
in the head versus four dooms five
punches to the head okay in the first
round and then then there's body for
doing landed 13 punches the body virgin
landed ten then in leg shots ver doom
landed 24 of 45 uh and over him landed
six of 12 and and I and I'm not
surprised by those numbers because for
Doom was the aggressor he was pressing
it the whole time and I watched Illinois
but yeah he's not necessarily a knocked
out artists were overhangs more of a
power play right and definitely a better
strike sure but I would definitely give
that first round based on that that
metric to Purdue and if you do that then
first round goes to bird Ihram second
round goes over in and of course the
third round goes to their doom so that's
why I was surprised by it I just wasn't
that surprised don't get the big uproar
at all look at that it's a great shot
there's a very actually a very good
technical fight man
it wasn't no it was not the photos again
me a lot of a lot of stress man oh there
there was so weird atom down yeah it
pops up there it is oh look at that
ooh legit that's that third round yeah
yeah I'm not sure what you're on it is
that my turn that's third yeah that's
where you got in trouble I think it's
bad
that's why was that blonde she's right
so that would be a tenant usually right
if you if you me him and knock him down
like that just depends for those two
minutes left I got well again
well you but like see what he can't say
is a robbery why not
that wasn't a robbery we've seen
robberies that's not like oh my god this
is ridiculous
can you said the first round was tough
to call yeah now I'm looking at the I'll
come on be well hold on I I called it
for I said ver doom one okay and the
realtor I'm super tough to call well now
the first round was very tough cause I
don't think anything happen I'm even
surprised by all these like landed by
target significance rights even though
for doom looks like he landed more I
actually would have said you know it
didn't look at those backing this goes
back to the horn Pacquiao's thing so ver
doom is a he's an outside striker that's
his style
so if you go based strictly off comp you
strike numbers on who's more active
again that is not how fight is judged or
scored I thought the score it's not I
thought the judges did weigh aggression
in favor of gun control
okay octagon control so okay so that
doesn't mean that does that direction
that means that doesn't mean wrong
punches okay either way I think that if
you look at the significant strikes at
this metric if this is true and I don't
know if it is it is okay then I then you
got to go with you've got to give it to
her dealer what why would you get to
Verdoux when a over evil and it's fifty
five percent of the significant strikes
off more bikes that he threw right which
so when he did throw as many right but
when he did he landed more of them that
he's our punch i would mean he's more
act accurate however I would also he's
also a harder puncher though so she's
not going to throw as many I understand
but wouldn't you weigh the fact that ver
doom landed 12 to 5 in the head for no
because we're doomed 13 Dylan and the
barber zooms through almost triple the
mallas punches I get but you kinda and
didn't do damage he didn't do damage but
I would even but with 24 strikes of the
legs versus six strikes if I have no
other metric to go by because neither
one of them got any damn
in that first round I'm gonna give it to
her do in the first round
it just it again it depends yeah I
didn't see anybody doing dance I thought
of Aryan act like I can't believe that
true because I was watching that too but
anyway yeah and then when you throw in
in the third round the fact that he gets
dropped I gotta get to do I think he
didn't know in the second you know he
did it with only two minutes left who
done it earlier and did more damage and
spent the rest of the like let's say he
did that in the first minute they spent
four minutes on top and doing damage and
going for submissions
that's a 10-8 because it happened with
such little time got back in I can
attend eight yeah he got back up right
I don't think use a robbery a tough
tough tubs are a tough one to judge yeah
but I'm not the best fight not at all
those guys just do not good dance
partners
I see synching with Woodley Wonder Boy
they're just not good dance partners
Bader Phil Davis just not get Danny
honest though amazing fighters together
or well no they're just for their Styles
Clash there's not good dance burners
they should not be matched up they just
shut it it's just not just got to move
on they should never fight again
I don't think Overeem deserves a title
shot after that know it like he wants um
well I think he gets dropped by although
he drops deep a first round right yeah
but I think it same thing happens yeah I
don't that happen too soon he's gonna
have to fight I don't know what might
they might give Francis a title Shafter
JDS they need some new blood for steeper
it's Cain Velasquez out and down to his
back in the back and then the main event
I thought was a main event saved I'm not
fully redeemed himself Jesus I call
Whitaker in the in the upset a long time
ago yes he did I was so impressed
because Whitaker in the first round goes
my leg is trashed his leg got trashed
and you know you could see it in the
final round he would hit like he he is
knee buckled and just brought it to him
those front kicks to the chest of yo
Romero Romero got tired mouth was open
and towards the issue with yo Romero
although in the fifth round he looked
good the brownies killing for a knock I
look good I was you know I I figured
Whitaker had really good cardio but I
was more impressed with yo remain on the
fifth
you got also the 26 year old versus the
40 year old in the actual fifth round
that's going to play a factor Whittaker
didn't slow down it felt like he just
stayed sharp and fasted cardio was
amazing and he's the new blood that guy
is amazing man this is his seventh fight
that seventh win I think in a row or
something like that
got me um well he came because he was at
70 and wasn't doing well there and then
came to 85 and the since he's been at 85
he's just same I like that look at look
at it look at him at 70 right you lose
his court McGee and switch decision
loses the Wonder Boy I was like I like
this guy's been freaking 85 yeah he's
just on a tear
I tear a tear you dismantle Jacare
dismantle Derek Brunson and then frickin
you know I'll classy older male the
older male had a real tough time take
him down - yes he did really really yes
he [ __ ] did his takedown offense was
sick and when when even when you're
Romero had his back he stood up he just
kept sprinting cage and standing up and
I was so blown away by that those that
was actually to me besides his striking
which is obviously amazing but his take
on me fence against yo Romero's
ridiculous right that was the fight I
mean if you want to take down the fence
enough crazy cuz I look great and then
they're not doing that remember when uh
Robin boxes on big round break down he's
like GSP Bisbing Antonio Marez announcer
it with these I can't fight that's not
happening yeah
the Bisbing Whitaker is happening 100%
yeah I mean I'll see what it means to
fix his knee but I've stuff fight for
Bisbing what's the damage on his knee to
me now I don't know yeah but visiting a
lot or the topic you're terrified for
visiting yeah but for business the best
matchup I think really oh versus over yo
I mean I think so
a machine dragged you on the later
rounds but because using witters does
Reggie oh yeah well yeah we're just like
- he's not wrestling yeah nature
yeah it's a it's a good fight though
yeah the card was in a nail-biter
they're big July cards on the 27th UFC
214 that's the that's the big momma
I wanted to ask you about before we move
on from this
so nuna is pulling out you do you have
any feelings as if maybe she should have
probably stayed in even though I know
she doesn't owe it to anyone else
okay know everyone that I'm always
athlete's first so when remember when
everyone got all up in arms about John
Jones not fighting
Chael Sonnen or whoever was Dan
Henderson cannon they're very polite
though made a final disable and yeah and
they want to replace with Dan Henderson
oh yeah with someone I forget remember
you got all the bad press for that as an
athlete man you only get so many fights
if this is a serious problem especially
for I'm gonna give her the benefit of
doubt she's a world [ __ ] champion so
I have no issues with it but here's and
neither should me buddy oh but let me
ask you this so so she was fine up until
the last day right so her weight table
horseshoe salmon issues yeah but the
weight cut is what brought on all this
stuff
right so her mean system in everything
else starts to crash and then like
Shevchenko even knew that she was like I
knew how much weight she wanted to keep
on yeah and then put back on to get an
advantage she played that game yeah so
she she mess it up on herself and now
she's taken away Valentina
all their work all their teams I'll tell
you guys 70 G's that she when they got
and she's gonna fight now in Edmonton so
they made most of the fans I'm thinking
about like I'm mad imagine all the fans
that came over and they [ __ ] she could
have made a decision
she got cleared but her thing was
bothering her a lot athlete of her
magnitude in her level even if it's that
big a deal you gotta trust especially if
you know for a level that that it's
actually really now this is the problem
also she doesn't know the fan shell I
know you and you guys aren't the one who
were gonna pay her bills if she gets
punched in the face and as you [ __ ]
her career up Poorna really like it's so
you cannot base off god I hope I don't
upset Shevchenko's families [ __ ] no but
only reason I'm saying ads because she
decided to do that way cut that way like
if she never had this before and she
said that's a chronic thing that she has
yeah I've never heard of it before but
I'm guessing if she truly drained her
body look at people
I've had it before like Maranello
tweeted out heat and it's some serious
[ __ ] man it's legit
you know I get bottom lines and we
should we should we owe it to a champion
like Amanda Nunez to take her word for
the fact that she couldn't fight I
promise you for a fighter to cancel day
of was that's the magnitude of that
that's a last and she knows the
repercussions it must've been a big deal
the other thing okay Shevchenko she's
not exactly bringing the Conor McGregor
fan base whether selling out this
[ __ ] stadium so the twenty people you
had comin over we'll figure it out let's
go to Edmonton trust me he'll figure out
you get or you also get extra 70 K for
your troubles not bad and then you have
do you run this fight Edmonton and build
it up even more
is it more time to kind of build it up
yeah it's not the end of the world
no definitely and it's also a reality
how about how about Jana Jinjin chick
was trying to I was all right that was
all she was begging Dana had to take the
fight she wanted to fight she's gonna
get [ __ ] about belts I don't care if I
lose I'm trying to save this car and I
want to fight god monster yeah they
showed her on the screen and she pointed
at Tony hey now make sure that she's
like hey look at this wins it'd be great
Tony loves her I take stone I said it
god I hope you get a hand job from you
on tonight she's all hope she just those
cow is ready man right there was she
she's a [ __ ] step right down walking
I'll tell you what they showed all that
like max Holloway Cody gar Brandt
everyone would keep everyone the crowd
everyone's there they showed Johanna got
by far the biggest chair she she's
become a superstar which is what they
need
and rightfully so hell yeah she was like
I don't care if I lose the belt I don't
care what it's for I will fight Cottle's
right huh woo you know you know what the
big issues the big hella tight' weed
this out I said no way she's medically
cleared it's not because we're cat-scans
or and whatever it's because pregnancy
tests take 72 hours for females come
back really really send me two hours
that's interesting but why you can take
a pregnancy test I know but they the way
they do it I don't send me two hours
they got to make sure something I can't
argue that'll be honest I pick something
to us I think it's never gonna happen
zowie damn 72 [ __ ] hours
that's amazing I would have loved to
have seen that oh my god over Lovejoy oh
my guess you would have been she would
have if you somehow would have pulled
that off yeah she would be back there
Shire ever
not really ship sank it was down to
she's a pure striker - and bigger Wow
is that she fought before happy really
yes you want a loss right yeah yeah in
pure striking I think she lost multiple
times if I'm yeah they did yeah she does
a much bigger gal much stronger sir
he'll probably whether that you want to
such a [ __ ] monster I'll fight right
now African myth of Jana builds that was
just good PR for no matter what right
yeah I was like oh hell yeah
but yeah the the the pen she tests for
the reasons any two hours if it's not a
terrible idea obviously your funerals
can happen but having people just as
backups yeah the problem is kept wait
but I think you get you paying whatever
you given this 20 or 30 grand group
grand just to make weight as in case
something happens you know why did he'll
then did you watch gay Chi versa
did I not [ __ ] college in yeah I said
your best fight of this right hand is
gay team I didn't tell my god oh my word
really oh my word you missed it oh yeah
I saw it
yeah I saw it I saw it yeah yeah he's
got a gate gate Ian Noctor
Johnson out against the cage I was crazy
but but Michael Johnson wobbled him yeah
wobble the few times I was a create his
name is so hard to pronounce JG alright
yeah because the way you look at it it
doesn't sound like a chi yeah yeah that
was WOW Johnson hits him he geek buckles
and then he comes it was that was crazy
it just broke Johnson yeah it's me in
certain see how ehe does with the upper
echelon the guys Tony first set off item
Kevin Lee SEDOL item to be you know
could be as soon as things I didn't see
it but all the top dives you beat John
sees right number five and people go
give them this guy in the skate now you
got to give them someone ranked higher
keys repeat number five state you should
just automatically be ranked 5 now 18
and OH
malte time world champion from World
Series fighting just Merc you're number
five guy in the world like the Johnson
he's just be number five and then what
you should do is he should fight one was
caught four guys
I wouldn't mind team against Tony
Ferguson how about at Eddie Alvarez
nothing so much fun if they fought I
mean I don't know how long it's gonna
he's gonna last the way you fight I
don't like him me at the upper upper
echelon I saw him at the fight I talked
to him a little bit I don't like his
fighting style against those those
elitist elite they're not committed
bangs they're not gonna sit and play
that game with you he bangs you dang
bangs
yeah that's all that's his thing in that
chin you know at what point you know
although Johnson out of those top top
four guys by the hardest hitter and he
eight dollars he's the most explosive
guys mayor Johnson beat Tony Ferguson 10
for his last loss but um I against was
upper echelon guys I don't see them
playing that game and I also don't see
him breaking them he broke my butt you
want to fight cause he broke Michael
Johnson yeah Michael Johnson that was
his fight to lose do you think you think
that Justin gave you will if he tries to
stand in the grill and bang they're
gonna do they're not gonna beat it yeah
but then again you go ahead and shoot on
them good luck taking that guy down for
some we're gonna use University known in
Colorado he's a monster to take down
yeah the biggest sold his game and I'm
not saying anything about a sumo school
I know jiu-jitsu doesn't work on
jiu-jitsu mm-hmm again those upper
echelon guys will expose that they will
force you to work on jujitsu meaning
you're going to learn how to defend a
dark joke by getting choked to sleep in
front of everyone and then you'll start
working on your darts joke defense try
try competing against Stony first was no
jujitsu if I can compete against to be
active any of these monsters see what
happens
try getting to that brawn war with a guy
like conor mcgregor at 55 let me know
how it works out for it but and this is
coming from a guy who I started I build
gate since day one I love the guy
understanding those upper echelon dudes
they look at what you don't do well and
they will force you to work on it
jumping back to Whitaker Romero when
Romero took Whitaker's back I was
surprised he didn't throw those hooks in
right away I was nature hot Bruno
you can read the back it's like that
freestyle rider garage it yeah they're
gonna choke Whittaker out okay
did you UFC how gates you tried to climb
the fence to do a backflip yeah he fell
down twice and then the third one he
finally got on John Wayne parted the
look at him dude I killed average if you
look at you I keep trying and trying it
I'm sorry gonna learn to lose otherwise
I mean just how about Jesse Taylor's
story
great comeback max you know about who
today so Jesse Taylor was on the
Ultimate Fighter before me what for an
early one maybe seven one of the early
1976 old-school winter seasons makes it
he's the guy who makes like me makes
this finale but the night of the finale
you know though so once you finish the
semifinal so you have three months off
before you have to fight it what's your
the main events that big lead up right
so it's your last night in the house so
we're going something fun
Jesse Taylor's that guy he's on a feed
in the house then that night he goes
nuts parties here at he wrecks his hotel
room he takes out the window of the limo
Dana sits down Hold'em goes you're just
not ready for this lifestyle you don't
let him fight so for the next how many
years he fights in these random [ __ ]
promotions and then finally gets and the
serious all that golf tuna find
redemption good god is it effort the
redemption for Jesse Taylor but this my
thing with that Shella it's a great
story and I love a good story you tell
me Jesse Taylor's gonna compete with the
top ten boys in the in those divisions
it's like all those guys now you get
some to the actual UFC caliber fighters
yeah I didn't work out before so
Redemption I get it and so it's such a
great story but you know you mess with
those top ten boys in that division it's
it's a tough [ __ ] go man said it took
a dangerous forest and it's a really
tough go and I saw I saw it boy
TJ Joe he's there in my hotel so I stay
at the Encore I was asking well what the
[ __ ] man yeah what is happening goes
Cody my it's gonna be Cody were swinging
for him to get better
I saw his back right yeah and examined
uh he had all the work done on it so you
know how imagine a widened
DJ say no to TJ what's that record he
doesn't think it's a super fight what do
you think I've been over so much but but
um it's not a Superfly I'm actually with
DJ on this like why would you find a guy
who's never made the way doesn't compete
in that weight class you're going for
the all-time record to be answering
Silva you're really not it's not in also
it's not that big of a superfight Adamic
Cruz might be or you know but it's not
and to risk it all that and the record
on this guy you know who's gonna be a
way bigger of a challenge it's not
really gonna change ratings you might
get 50,000 more pay-per-view buys off it
it's technically not a super fight
super fights John Jones versus Cain
Velasquez super fights you know Luke
Rockhold vs. or dude those are super
fast something that people when you
think of a super fight you want you want
the [ __ ] there's levels to this game
you know what the level the super fight
is Conor McGregor Floyd Mayweather
that's a super fight so where does it
get on that scale well it to give you
that it's not on the scale how many
here's there's this other thing we get
to that but here's the other thing is
and I was not aware of this they
actually offered DJ a lot of money and
he still send out huh which I found
interesting yeah
hi sources told me that they offer DJ a
shitload of money so I know huh
I think there's much other gang I was
doing for DJ's like nah man I thought
the money thing yeah hey your eyes it
you got hippo eyes again I was like go
do it
see this is what I'm trying to get
trying to peel the layer the onion back
will be in soo well the Conor McGregor
for mayweather fight is so big that it
lands on the weekend I was supposed to
do DC now granted a lot of my fans are
fight fans but but even the improve your
fans alarm flight light they were like
hey listen do you want to cancel this
and I told you that I was in the room
with you our agent right we're going on
my schedule he goes up right as uh-oh
cancel everything anyone you have that
love came to me came to us first I think
we're gonna do it I was like I don't
know and they're like listen you know I
told
No and the truth is Saturday might be a
ghost town because of this fight
everybody's gonna be watching it yeah
they all new ones but you never have
ever have a club come to a headliner
girl yeah they just played in that tell
you the boobs so that's how you know
that Conor McGregor has it is a bigger
draw than I am this like this what I
find fascinating is what Comics egos we
might now still do it good lot to people
show up yeah good luck when when they
when they told me I went no you can't do
that too bad no one will show up there
will be no one yeah
menus can be completely come on down to
see Bryan Callen and it's comedy
stylings if I can record the fisa
mayweather verify guys this guy is
hilarious it's crazy
oh my god no one needs to do that man
nobody needs to do that yeah it's me
interesting men do going on this press
tour to the press tour is going to be I
mean time on the biggest press tour of
all times can be bananas and you've been
in Connors you've been in Connors camp
hero but - camp but I've been yeah it's
gonna be fun yeah Sabine sting it's me
and Pauly mal janani Mountain Nagi Malan
Island and Nagi Malan that is also a
brilliant man should be interesting
arguing with that gentleman hopefully
not arguing two months yeah you'll see
it some convention sure the first one is
about Floyd apparently he's asking the
IRS to hold back on back-tested back
taxes that he needs to pay until after
the Conor McGregor fight and I think you
read already and I read somewhere it was
on 6 million is when I write under 6
million in taxes how come I getting his
taxes again doesn't even can again add
this add another check for Connor under
this this again you have 40 year old
through tired a while ago for reasons
hasn't fought in a while now he's doing
the fight we know for money stuff when
you're fighting just for money man why
is he why did he do this can you explain
why the [ __ ] explain with with animate
with accountants and everything why was
you not holiday here boys I'm saying why
would you not pay taxes
man don't you have an accountant who
goes hey dude can go to jail
got it file our tax return I don't
understand this I really don't I don't
understand it it makes no sense to me
it's the craziest thing I've ever seen
you got a six million dollar tax lien at
you no liability his assets are
primarily illiquid it's like sewing all
that cash you need 220 million for the
mini Pacquiao fight I mean how do you
not have five million to pay your taxes
right a failure to pay a penalty is to
be sly person he's earned seven hundred
million dollars in his 49 five
professional career he goes broke I'm
gonna freak the [ __ ] out he says yeah
then freak out now
are you brand new to that I don't care I
think have you never seen the
documentary going broke these guys
who've made more money than Floyd you've
been broke I know that yeah it's
outrageous like apparently Johnny Depp
who's made seven hundred million dollars
as an actor ah he's according to
interviews Steven Smith mayweather
showed Smith his Las Vegas home garage
with seven cars that he said we're close
were close to 15 million dollars I just
can't tell us meditate on the cars but
did not drive them awesome good stuff
unless you stuff like this like in in
other news floyd mayweather lives in Las
Vegas it's like of course any Gamble's
like a much of what yeah no one finds it
strange he's coming every time to fight
Conor McGregor what needs the money I
lived that life he needs the money yeah
me and lookit I need a lot of money he
needs a lot of me you need a guy like
telling McGregor to get you that money
Thomas Gregg is not footed granted I'll
see the money fight Conor McGregor is
not fighting for just the money he does
not have tax issues mm-hmm another plus
for Connor family please save your money
you should go talk to em they serious
they do it yes when I heard some were
civilians in the world I understand what
you guys how to do with the work 700
million dollars come on man how crazier
look I go to Whole Foods a lot and I
feel like I'm indulging
but you know I spent money and wine not
a lot but I don't know man you also
don't have seven hundred million dollars
I know but Jesus what what I can't I
can't
I like how you what a black athlete with
money troubles yeah what the [ __ ] is
happening here what's wrong with you in
other news he also likes [ __ ]
Gatorade Brian I mean it's crazy
Brendan I look at it so like yeah no
[ __ ] what else you got chin I mean look
look my ties want to know what you 100
what he can't read and write and but he
doesn't pay his taxes no the guy seems
like he's got in wads it's got
accountants oh and I'm sure the people
around him are brilliant looking out for
his future yeah they're it's so weird
it's like his entourage taking advantage
thing that they're making money off him
you think they're on the payroll
anyone I know was it like Oh market
honest me listen oh my god he has tax
roms everyone knows you know [ __ ] okay I
understand it but look at me look Mike
Tyson went to $209 I get it 700 million
dollars and let's just take the taxes
away on everything else so now we're
left with I'm just going to be
conservative 400 350 million let's just
be conservative all right um I do really
if we're doing can you just do 350
million hey bro he's broke this is a
waste of your time he spent a shitload
of money
he has houses and houses and cars and
he's gone the clubs and he has the email
Yangtze strip clubs and he has [ __ ]
baby mamas ideas a kid he'd be making a
conservative portfolio really
conservative he could be making at 300
million dollars I mean you keep making I
can't get into it let's just say 300 200
he's still making 24 million dollars a
year on interest like how do you spend
two million dollars a month you do did
the answer is you can and you do with
those good too this is a perfect
transition so James Harden his new
contract with the Houston Rockets am I
doing this right he to lengthen it to
four years it's going to end up being
around 228 million total he was just
taking what was a more than just in
glove
no ideas I've written without him I
would a [ __ ] kidnapping I may say
this is the biggest contract signing
beating Steph Curry so how much is that
per year so for year so he signed a 41
hundred million extension yeah
gg-go 170 all he will now earn two
hundred twenty-eight million total to
the end of his contract so his contracts
for how long four years four years two
and twenty eight million Jesus fussing
Mike the thing is they're worth it - I
like LeBron James tweet when Steph Curry
four years what was it four years 220
million something like that he's
basically doing 46 million a year for
what it is but lavanya's everyone's
freaking out
imagine how much he's worth to the team
like this no one should be surprised by
this I think I much money LeBron James
generates for the Cleveland Cavaliers I
can't pay much nihilism
you're not Steph Curry like you can't
care they win championships think that
they're building a brand new stadium for
like 2g billion dollars that another
happens out Steph Curry yeah so we look
at like holy [ __ ] that's crazy and
fighters should take notes man no you're
worse no one knows that more than these
guys but there's also Union there's a
plenty Association app all that but
never seen James Harden without his
beard
I haven't bring James Hunt up without
his bid I'll figure it out he they go
why did you grow a bag just cuz I looked
awkward without it he just looks like if
you if you told me this guy's top three
best players in the NBA and he want done
your face go that far left with the
beard no bid the style exciting to try
and sell you a pair of sketches at
footlocker well he's got it needs at an
Invisalign just like Oh Breyer let's
start with that but how much better does
he look with a beer yeah
mr. steel your girl on the left yeah mr.
steel your bike on the right yeah yeah
yeah well one if there is music her
there's right she's like I'm just
kidding yeah how long we're gonna get a
lot about uh yeah one is like he looks
kind of like a warrior like in Game of
Thrones I can DeLong's on a horse with
like a scimitar and the other one is mmm
I mean I guess you don't watch the movie
the show but he looks he looks like kind
of like a double
way better with the beardo because way
better and how much better does crit
blow up when she [ __ ] ditch quite
here - Ian I'm here just blew up yeah I
mean grandi is great before but now he's
just [ __ ] monster I almost won MVP
but Westbrook got it hmm let's get chin
all right funny he's looking out the
beard though okay so there's a couple in
Pittsburgh and if you believe the story
or not it's really hard to believe but a
news you know a news station went there
and they said it's true that they have
an alarm clock stuck in their wall yeah
because he was like when they were first
building their house he put it to the
vent saying he timed it at a certain
time to go off so he'll know where to
like he'll know what area to drill the
TV like mounting holes in yeah cuz he'll
know where the clock is like okay here
is on the drill up here not even sure if
that makes sense but it's been going off
at the same time for 13 years so there's
a war there's a clock in the wall in the
wall that he dropped it I had hippo eyes
and it's going on for 13 years I had the
reason why it goes on for 13 years is
because it has some crazy rayovac
battery that just lasts forever and a
virgin years ago there the screw gun
[ __ ] I said I bought batteries [ __ ]
two months gonna have issues with them I
got hippo eyes
here's the show this is the clock going
off of Ross yeah until the walls come
alive with the sound of a 13 year old
alarm clock I'll show you where this
thing's lettuce reporters it's a long
Sam Ford asses yeah say how would you
like to be the guy breaking this news
guy hey Larry I got it I got it I got
some for you a break on this couple
they're old as [ __ ] in the middle of
nowhere they have a clock going off in
there wallaby
it will not go investigate investigate
for some it goes how the suit on act
like you want to be there oh yeah $98
hours to get down there with the van and
that could be very they're interviewing
Sylvia Lynn yeah it's great all right
this next one is actually pretty sick a
kid in Colorado
camping got woken up by the sound of a
crunching sound and it was a black bear
that got into his tent and started
chewing on his head
what he woke up to him true on his head
yeah he heard the sounds of crunching
and you mean sick you mean disgusting
disgusting cuz when the kids say sick
there'd be like cool this is actually
pretty cool though yeah
and cool so he seems fine also a kind of
baby bear with it that's what I'm saying
my dad it's all my fault again look at
that looks like those are two little
paint like a little scratches that you
get when when you're holding your son
and he's scratching at your face you're
not a man any any cats hold on scroll
down to him what's that say it says uh
the crunching noise I guess was the
piece scraping against the skull that
dug in the team who teaches what
wilderness survival yeah they didn't
teach you this [ __ ] did they he wake up
in a tent appears balls-deep on your
head with his teeth they didn't run over
that one the catalog deal another ID
office near teens were 12 senior tempers
are sleeping nothing were hurt well I
bet those 12 and 13 yards were like
[ __ ] lawn
no one behaved in at 12 see ya this guy
survived a polar bear attack that's a
different thing and his buddy shot the
polar bear but he had he was pretty much
scalped
this has to be a smaller bear than just
looking at the teeth marks it just says
it dragged him 12 feet oh and he was
punching him in the face until I let go
it's not a eat him it's kind of hungry
any bears feed me bears doing beer [ __ ]
yes D Brunel says it when a black bear
bites you like that its predatory it's
trying to eat you so fight like a
[ __ ] if I leave no [ __ ] well no
because some birds are
so some bears will come at you here Tori
you're in your tent and it seems pulling
you up to eat you yeah you got a fight
who would who would me alright I guess
I'm guys I'm gonna die yeah
imagine black people gonna yeah polar
bear grizzly bear can grab you by the
ass it's generally I might be asking
Frank Mir is finally released from his
UFC contract he wanted this I wanted it
yes so he's finally let go cuz I want to
go over the belt or you just want to
make my let's get out the UFC like and
they won't let em fight we'll get the
suspension then as well right so there's
the suspension they're not sure if it's
going to end there not because of this
but no it doesn't this it's it's the
Commission Thunder the Commission I want
I think they said that you might be able
to yeah hada I said they he might be
able to get off earlier well he can
fighting
Russia or you can fight another
sanctioned event you know events that
don't go here to the rules and
regulations of you son and the
Commission's who suspended them so he
could fight like okay you're right it
Rison okay I see if you could fight in a
different kind of sort of deals yeah but
don't tell anything either last yeah you
know I think April next year yeah so if
you let's fight soon we can fight like
ACB or something like that which
accommodates for our managers gonna
fighting that thing do that yeah oh yeah
yeah what am i fighting come - come on
son yeah Mitrione how about I give you 1
million better example DC Dominick Cruz
I mean there's I'm thinking of an
ownership I'll take another a succesful
fighting for a World Series how did I
just popped in my head here you old
school man it's very simple still fine
no but he did Pfeifer that's awesome
ocean anyone French chin it's not that
old cause all the guys who fight who
come to mentality badges coming up with
names like chapeau and the suspension I
got wrong to you this is meant to get
you thinking like a rare Wanderlei in
the certain guys what even if even the
Commission in LA says you're suspended
you can fight outside you're never gonna
be allowed to come back here though they
do not look lightly on that I think
that's all oh wait this one this is an
Oklahoma a guy proposed to his
girlfriend while he was being arrested a
know better late than never
better late than even see him on his
knees can't get here as officers
arresting Brandon Thompson for six
awards and then she said yes plan to
propose to his girlfriend that day and
officers let him go ahead with the
proposal while still in handcuffs
God can't take the cuffs off for seconds
oh boy I could have been a big boy could
have been the old I'm gonna fake
proposing and then I'm gonna run
although he doesn't look like he's like
you don't walk down their muzzle [ __ ]
and do it now and I'll find her to vomit
on during alive does it say how would he
went away for he had like six
outstanding warrants explaining go away
for a little while
having six outs anyone yeah yeah this is
on his bird you want a safe you want a
warm house a warm bed come I did it
safer with the witness for the warrants
yeah hope nesting violence not afraid
have you done I think it's all like you
know and there's a cool the officers
were cool he was like yes is the he's a
hey can my mom who hit the wedding ring
in the room right yeah go ahead man you
get a proposed her Wow see ya alright
one last one it's kind of romantic I
guess this is a hit and run
okay you know what bicyclists go on they
take up an entire Lane when it happened
right in [ __ ] people get annoyed
right and then they don't stop at the
stop signs or follow the traffic lights
yet they want to be taken through yeah
[ __ ] be autonomy
so this do diddily me one car passes the
guys but the next car so this one passes
him the next car you can see here he
hits him and he hits them they think
it's on purpose like he got frustrated
too just like a lot of people do kind of
like that
turns out way that guy is a Dean of a
university he looks like a mean son of a
[ __ ]
he sure does he just was like you know
what today i school dean of students you
know rounded Radiological well he did he
just take off took off hit and run so
yeah that's on purpose I hate this yeah
hey look I I kind of secretly wanted to
go you hate but that guy's annoying
don't take up the whole [ __ ] road
you're a DS okay - that's why like I can
see yang do it and also but also hey man
if you're a [ __ ] cyclist and you got
all big matching gear on whatever the
[ __ ] uniform you're win yeah unless
you're preparing for the Tour de France
do not wear all that [ __ ] are they
paying any of your bills unless you are
officially sponsored by any one of those
companies do not match your top your
pants to shoes the helmet you guys me
[ __ ] you go back - can you go back
down I want to see what it says upper
here now go all the way right there
isn't that where it isn't that the guy
keep going
right there yeah this is a guy was
biking for the first time
since childhood this is the first time
he God he buys all the gear and gifts on
and he's like today I'm going to take up
the whole Road and I'm at a road by gay
game I was just telling of the whole
time road kind of a spaz is it safe to
say that he's a bit of a spaz he's just
I don't know he guys like this annoy me
just get the [ __ ] out of the way bro how
about the demons like he's in his
[ __ ] like that explores a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you food cache you know hey I don't want
to do that I would just love like like
be take the wheel and I just go pick you
at the side that's legit
that's legit you can run him over our
vehicle I don't want to kill him now I
just want to push him into the [ __ ]
bushes yes yeah if it's [ __ ] here is
he's all yeah alright buddy I'm a
vehicle to like just have ride second oh
he's flying I've got right up boom
that's what you [ __ ] get like I just
wish I had something on my car that a
hand that would push out just go back
well no I wish I had some that came out
the front and people cut me off
it just goes thank you on the trunk like
what the [ __ ] was that
just deep shock God or just something on
the spokes just you can actually get mad
max' though yeah I mean I get it it's
very annoying but you can't hit somebody
with two times but also hey bus was you
not part of the road you certainly are
not hit is for older I didn't [ __ ] over
and you know what I would personally I
would never ride on a road in the middle
of nowhere because I expect the psycho
how many times go there maybe 100 maybe
one of those water I always expect what
I want to do throat a guy I hear that
car it just takes a little it sorry
[ __ ] you you know bad I'm always ready
for it no I don't trust people
I don't you're you're basically trusting
when you're at the cyclist it Craig
member wrong you're trusting literally
everybody who drives by you and it takes
one psycho and it's a known fact that
some people enjoy running you off the
road motorcycles talk about this all
time so when I was in high school I'm
riding a bike I never ride
bikes and I never will but I have no
been riding the bike borrow my friends
bikes I want to go get a soda or some
[ __ ] riding a bike kids coming the other
way I just see a kid come out with a
soda can and he just threw it at me your
face looking up and last minute I ducked
I like put my head down hit me on the
top of the Harper please I love it and
it was open anyway canoes you know it
and it hurt like a [ __ ] and what
I did I kept on biking you did my story
got off you the [ __ ] truth I was
bleeding I was all [ __ ] up the lady
behind the counter called the cops cops
came and they interviewed me and I said
is this guy's make oh you know it's a
salt that's the only kid Oregon kids
whose ha he do spin they were trying to
counter with you you know so it's ready
kill you mean II don't I try to kill
myself the bike in hilarious hesitate I
said I got [ __ ] yeah hilarious yeah
exactly
before they hit you ready to say that
you say Eddie yeah Vegas what he took
through the spokes I guess yeah now
they're trying to hit me in the face
with an edge realizing the guy I'll be
like well here's a biker cage was empty
no with a full soda cantaloupe opened
yeah and threw it hard he like drinking
with his buddies with is this [ __ ]
human shrine I was like what's this
Billy yep
dude he's gonna trucking his way I saw
Molly he's gonna move that truck yeah
toward me with it Troy Aikman no he's in
a moving truck coming toward me I was
riding against him out of moving yet so
if they're telling Michael Vick yeah
dude and he chucked it at home ah ah hey
that's why I did her and her it was
dangerous he was that her then was it
Johnny Unitas don't [ __ ] slow that
you say what you wanna say I was saying
he's coming toward me on the road so I'm
going against traffic on the road block
yeah I'm on the road llama I think I was
on the sidewalk with her and he did I
just see him reach out and I that guy
that guy's gonna throw that [ __ ] ball
laughter that's not happy I just put my
head down any but again by the way not
surprised what I expected what I expect
you but it's like yes I did help me I've
been all over the baikonur expect you
him the Fox face or the soda can it's
like but if I go high
go camping which again look at me yeah
never no I never do I'm doing something
okay me with my girl with my with my
wife and it's a romantic thing I'm
bringing a pistol with me I'm packing a
[ __ ] 45 or a 9-millimeter why I
expect you know because I bear it not
even barest but maybe but more
importantly just random psycho in the
woods waiting for me I agree that's it I
agree with that 100 I don't know about
riding your bike expected in the face of
the crush orange so after this area I
feel like that I got one even I'm I told
you but even when I was a kid like we
would do things like that not yet harder
cyclist in the face would bike to it we
told rocks at cars or moon cars or
dingdong in ditch or you know just to
egg places I feel like nowadays like it
like you find out Oh kid egged a car and
the car ran off the road Todd I'm fired
six all six members of family are killed
yeah like maybe just was it that's
always happen but yeah but I don't
remember back there like no one was
dying and [ __ ] kids do [ __ ] like break
windows and kill other people you know
they break windows and children fire the
killer drifter you know little things
like that
yeah I don't know yeah like kids of
really advanced in a bad way these days
yeah it depends you always have the kids
will cut the braces card for the game
you always have your your psychos you
have well they're always gonna be this
yeah so they did this this this this was
actually this is good for dropping
knowledge because Robert so the dropping
knowledge was that what what they did a
really interesting study and they've
done several of these where they take
they take kids who are having emotional
problems okay they're kind of bad kids
and they had a several program so they
take a bunch of the kids they're all bad
and they bring them to the countryside
and they teach them sports and they
teach them to fish and they'd given a
lot of attention and they're taught
academics and you know they're taught
that there's they're in the inner city
and it was all inner-city kids they're
in a concrete jungle get them out to a
farm teach them at a farm teach them how
to do sports and they're all together
and teach them community the
here's a problem so much about it is
problem we got worse do you know why -
they were on their own so the social
sciences they're around other cycles
yeah and the biggest psychos would teach
the last psycho kids the real tricks
yeah because they get there they went
being these amateurs and they turned in
together PhD in crime Robbins in prison
direct like you're going like these
little robbers and come out with like
your [ __ ] well mastering cocaine yeah
so a lot of the kids who might be
sensitive having a behavioral issues
they've been damaged they've been abused
those kids are still salvageable problem
is in a large group like that about
three sociopaths about three psychotic
alphas oh yeah
and their master manipulators those
three kids can take a group of twenty
five turn rat criminal cheese they can
turn right criminal so these now they
don't do that now they're like you don't
put a bunch of bad eggs together because
the worst eggs will make all the other
bad eggs that have a chance way would
you kill the worst eggs kill the worst
things you just there their heads off
game will throw the big programs that
they were doing this social scientist
goes put the brakes on for a second we
didn't take this new account it's just
our London Jew because that works yeah
that's another one oh what'd he do
that's another again you around the
other body yeah so though dudes the
foster system which are of course what
70% of all inmates went to the foster
system or something yeah eight yeah it's
not good to keep dropping on so so if
your kid has a bad friend make sure you
throw it from 100% you and I talked
about this how important it is to
surround yourself with you know people
that aren't completely online
we all have [ __ ] friends but you know
delete do we have our boy Joel Gerson
here's who's staying with - Leah - Leah
said - creature of habit
he'll wake up it Chris will go to bed to
wake up at 12
I can't wait to roast him for this and
he'll go have some coffee then he'll be
on his phone this is routine oh yeah
any-any won't eat won't eat until like
late night late night after he's done a
set anything at least but I think is
with him you know he's live in the
college life like that's our rock star
rock star but you can live in the comic
life right he's doing sets every night
like a monster no doubt I also figured
out I meant to send this text
have you ever noticed I mean not you but
if your nose he hangs out with the ugly
son tries you've ever seen so he can
ever know set so he came up area you
know might be the only peacock yeah I
don't worry about here up is a somewhat
me and Brian beginning bike maybe hit me
on it I know what he's doing I always
done you are he's like a pretty girl
with ugly friends might a pretty girl
with all fat I think you're so right I
looked at his on trying on it stop
fellas
another good family around these guys
you're ten you know with our crew you're
a solid eight maybe maybe a seven around
these guys you're a hardcore ten not
only that did you guys are he's not
talking about me no not imagine UPS yeah
you exam about his usual thing overage
guys with the longer here unlock some of
those weirdos and they like do anything
you ask them to do they ugly we were
hanging we were with Joe were and me
Christian and his four friends and we're
at swingers and Chris was referring to
them as this it's like 1:00 in the
morning is eating he goes hey sidekicks
stop talking for a second and then he go
hey three guys who would have three
lines only fundraiser life be quiet
right now
he's so [ __ ] of course he's roasting me
and I'm Rosa de cristal loves to no
notice his answer has no one very good
like there you guys hey you guy who I
just met look more like an undercover
cop with your sunken eyes in your short
generic care anyway suppose you didn't
use the word generically doesn't know
what that word means ladies and
gentlemen I want you to come out the
twenty 21st and 22nd to the comedy zone
in North Carolina Charlotte North
Carolina where I will be and I'll be at
Kappa Cleopatra in Montreal that is this
the end of this month
Brendon were you going to be men where
am I going to be I'm glad you brought
that up be and I'm actually looking
right now all the shows in London Dublin
are sold out I think they're thinking of
adding a matinee show that Monday and
Dublin the other ones are adding nothing
those are all sold out so forget about
it
but Phoenix July 20th Salt Lake City on
the 21st that one is almost sold out
Toronto on the 27th ooh
Chicago on the 29th Detroit on the 30th
and then I head on down to London Dublin
feedback' for everything you ever need
ever
Bryan Callen job related this is the
final kid we're out